Until last week, I didn't know this tape
existed.
Some of you are too young to even know
what this is. Back in the day, people
used these things to record. You put one
of these in a camcorder and it would
store your video footage.
I didn't even remember we had a
camcorder back then. It apparently
wasn't a great camcorder because the
footage isn't very high quality, but I
was looking through an old box last week
and I found this tape and it said
"Nabeel's Baptism".
I was in the pool that day. My wife was
taking pictures. I didn't remember
anyone recording Nabeel's Baptism. My
wife didn't remember anyone recording
Nabeel's Baptism. Nabeel never
remembered anyone recording his Baptism.
This is footage from 2005, over 20 years
ago. So, we weren't even thinking about
YouTube.
Apparently, someone used our camcorder
to record the baptism and then we put
the tape in a box and forgot about it.
So, I found this last week. I have
nothing that will play this tape, so I
had to take it to a place that converts
old tapes to MP4 files. They told me it
was ready yesterday, so I got it. The
audio was pretty bad because whoever was
recording was standing beside a loud air
conditioning unit. Thaddeus used a
program to massively reduce all the
background noise, which distorts our
voices and our words a bit, but here it
is.
Never seen by anyone before except me
when I watched it yesterday and then a
few friends when I asked them about
reducing the background noise.
Let's watch.
>> [applause]
>> I'm over
This feels you were here a little while
ago. This is Nabeel Qureshi.
Been my best friend
about 4 years now.
We've
We've been We've been through it. We've
been through it. We've been
We're ready to stab each other with
swords. It's uh
So,
been a been an awesome awesome time.
Lots of
year-long debates and so on. It's uh
Been a great time. I just like to say
that there are
You know there are a lot of
great days in history.
This day that
Neil Armstrong walked on the moon.
One small step for man, one giant leap
for mankind. That was That was a great
day. This uh
This day that Benjamin Franklin took his
kite out into the thunderstorm and
discovered that lightning is is
electrical. That was
That was a great day.
This day that
Martin Luther King said, "I have a
dream." This day that Patrick Henry
said, "Give me liberty or give me
death." And then
This day that David Wood baptized me and
Koresh
jumped in the swimming pool.
>> [laughter]
>> I don't know if any of you have ever had
a a best friend or a best buddy who just
wasn't
wasn't saved and you really wanted him
to be your your spiritual brother, too.
And And uh well, when that happens, it's
You know, it's a it's a great day. So,
it's a tremendous honor for me.
Neil,
you accepted Jesus Christ in your life
as your savior.
Yes.
This is your uh This is your public
profession of faith. So,
just tell everyone what you believe.
Yes.
I believe simply what the Lord put in me
and laid.
I call that was an infant
being tossed in the ocean by every wave
being blown by every wind.
So, I asked the Lord personally
because I believed
even though I was a Muslim, I believed
in Matthew 7:7 where he
"Ask and you shall receive, seek and you
shall find,
knock and the door will be opened for
you."
I believe that with all my heart. So, I
asked.
I asked in December. December 19th of
last year, I asked.
I asked again in February.
Then I asked again in April.
Each time the Lord showed me the path.
And one time,
he showed me specifically.
The Lord himself gave me a dream that
was
Luke 13:22.
In the dream,
I was at the narrow door.
The door on which I was to knock.
In Luke 13:22,
men said to the Lord,
"Are many people going to be saved?"
The Lord says,
"Give every effort to enter the narrow
door,
which is many will try to and few will
be able.
For when the owner of the house comes
and closes the door,
people will knock,
but the door will not be open. And
they'll begin to ask for the key and
they can try that.
The Lord will say,
"I did not know you or where you are
from."
The answer was to me to find the Lord.
And I knew who he was at that point. I
was told who he was.
He was the Lord Jesus Christ.
And I had to know him in order to save.
I had to know him in order to follow the
truth.
The Lord showed me three times the path.
And now, today, I know for a fact in the
bottom of my heart,
the Lord Jesus Christ died for our sins
and he loves me.
And by making this public profession of
my faith,
I will become part of his body.
And then I forever become his servant
and do as he has me do.
May he guide me. May he guide all of us.
And I believe from the bottom of my
heart that from this day forth
I will dedicate my life
to the path, the way of this Jesus.
Amen.
>> [applause]
>> Nabeel, based on your profession of
faith, I baptize you,
my brother,
in the name of the Father, the Son,
and Holy Spirit.
>> [cheering and applause]
[applause]
>> Sadly, the footage ends there. I say
sadly because right after that, Nabeel
put his hands in the air, which you may
have seen in one of the pictures I
posted years ago.
If you're not familiar with Nabeel's
story, check out a video of his
testimony, or grab a copy of his book,
Seeking Allah, Finding Jesus. The links
are in the description.
And if you haven't decided to follow
Jesus,
and you haven't been baptized,
what are you waiting for?
>> [music]
[music]